hello everybody big day for the market
in one hour from now we have CPI data
okay when I upload this video we're
probably only gonna have 15 minutes or
so so please watch this video quickly
and then you'll want to have some
company of what we can see during the
CPI okay now
the chart okay we were talking about
this structure yesterday again we're
still in the range okay here you could
say you know with we've we've broken the
4 out of 50 mate that was resistancy
okay now we're testing a support and
we're saying that the structure was
looking bullish because you can hear you
know we have support over the 50m in the
four-hour time frame here and now over
the mid-range okay
this liquidity Port has been retraced
and you know if today it wasn't a CPI
data they then you know we will be
preparing our long stewards this week
okay without any hesitation okay if
today wasn't CPA data we'll be running
Longs like a mad trade okay because yes
you know we have support here
support here and a long week to the
upside okay and a lot of liquidity here
now the thing is that today CPI data so
these are marketized mainly driven by
data so we can see
anything today okay it depends on what
the data is now if we look at the chart
I will tell you that you know you have a
work to the website
okay first let me remove this liquidity
pool so I'm trying to do this video
quite quickly we have this work to the
website here okay and we have all of
liquidity in this one here also okay
between Thirty One Thousand seven
hundred and thirty one thousand eight
hundred so in this one over here we've
got a lot of liquidity
all right
um so if it wasn't simply added that we
would probably favor you know a pushed
towards this 50 of the week
here we will take a lot of our profits
and then the next take profits would be
the 100 of the week and also uh the
deviation here above the right size at
31 700 31 800 from here then what we
want to see is a verb get back inside
the range and as soon as we're back into
the range then we go short
okay and here is what I would target
range lows and of course uh if you have
a clear deviation above the range highs
then we would expect a breakout in the
opposite direction okay that will be
below the range lows and that could take
you to 20 okay 500 or 29k okay
um but today with CPI data we have to be
a careful okay because there is going to
be a lot of volatility so I don't
recommend you Trading
at least wait 30 minutes or 45 minutes
after the data has been released okay
that means that if the data comes out a
half 12 UTC time then at least wait
until 1 pm okay or even quarter past one
all right now the data okay let's talk
about the data
um this is purely speculation because
it's very difficult to tell but
basically
in the previous uh data we had four
percent in the previous API
are now economists are expecting to the
one percent okay
um
what I think is that of course you know
um this is a big jump It's 0.9 percent
it seems to me like a really big change
again you know this drop also you know
it would be because there are a lot of
volatile uh elements in the CPI reading
the nav come down but you know we're
expecting them to probably have another
bounce later in the year okay so of
course CPI ticket with a pins of Soul
because it doesn't always show the
reality now
um we care about the chart so if this
thing is gonna move the charge then we
want to pay attention to this but if we
get less than one percent
okay
and even more 2.9 percent then the the
charts you know Bitcoin is gonna rip to
the upside
okay why because if you get imagine two
to nine percent you're already
time very close to the FED inflation
Target okay that is two percent so I
mean it's kind of a psychological number
two to nine percent because you're
already in the two percent Zone
um again I don't think we're gonna get
to the nine percent okay but I do each
other nine percent get ready because
this is gonna rip to the upside no
doubts okay now
uh if you get four percent of course
this this thing is when I go during it's
gonna go very low
but uh the most realistic is scenario in
my opinion is uh if you get something
like uh imagine three to three percent
three to four percent did I mean that to
me
it makes it's quite it's more likely
that if you get two to nine percent of
your four percent okay imagine three
percent three to four percent okay in
that case then you have the CPI quite
interesting because yes it came lower
okay so this is when you see fake moves
in the chart okay that could mean okay
you know when we have CPI it's very
likely that we have uh one thousand or
two thousand dollars a move okay right
now we're at thirty thousand seven
hundred one thousand dollars move would
post those sorry
with places in 31 700 Zone okay and one
thousand dollars moved down would take
us to the range lows okay now if you get
something like three dot three percent
three dot four percent why it's more
likely that we see a false move that
could be in my opinion there could be a
false move to the downside okay that is
when I leave large liquidity booster for
example this one here or this one here
we're talking about large red candles
okay
and probably they would do a deviation
below range loads this is something that
I've uh talked in the Sunday update go
to Twitter read again this one update
because this is an area statement being
played today okay then you would see a
deviation below range lows and as soon
as you get back inside
okay and you test your support then you
know run long Skies this is what I'm
gonna do again it's a financial advice
this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna run
my lungs to the 50 of the week okay that
in this scenario that we see three to
three percent three to four percent
three to five percent
and we see an immediate dump okay and of
course you know if we do a deviation
we'll range loads and get back inside
you know touch my trigger to go long all
right uh but in general terms guys be
very careful because today the market is
gonna be wild
um don't go with a lot of Leverage don't
try to guess what the number is going to
be and how the market is going to react
to because it's really hard
even for Traders like me that you know I
like to trade uh I like to I mean stay
tuned with the news announcements the
data and draw projections speculate it
is still very difficult for me okay
there is nothing more difficult for a
trade that to trade
during you know CPI fomc non-farm
payrolls so be very careful I'm gonna
wait 30 minutes or 45 minutes after the
data has come out and then I'm gonna
decide what trade I'm gonna take okay
but yes
if you see uh you know something between
three to one percent of four percent and
you see a quick drop to the downside
deviation get back inside the range then
that's a good entry a good entry okay so
I'm talking too fast that's a good entry
to Target again the mid-range and of
course the 50 of the week that has to
get filled hasn't got filled yet and yes
the work really started you guys it
works in one time frame check this out
yesterday 15 minutes time frame what do
you see here
what do you see here my guys you see up
week
what happened to that week okay it gets
filled okay almost to Dollar check that
out okay if we draw this
check it out
almost to the dollar then it drops again
okay
um then in this setups it's only about
looking for an rent report once you know
that the liquidity is up there this is
what I also said yesterday in Twitter
once you export what the liquidity is
you've done half the job done okay now
if the liquidity is up here you have to
find an entry point
in this case that could be the 50ma or
the mid-range as you can see all right
so
um for now I'll tell you the liquidity
is mainly to the upside okay if it
wasn't today CPI data I would be long I
could have been along today but we have
CPI data Anything Can Happen be careful
and just React to what the price
delivers okay guys
so anyway guys I don't want to take a
bunch of your time because I want to
upload this video very quickly thank you
so much for your support
and I'll see you soon